あの...ずっと
2年前ぐらいから遊戯王やってて
で、この季節になると来るんですよね　そのぉ
世界大会
遊戯王の世界一を決める大会があって
各店舗で予選が行われてて
それで勝ち上がった人が　こう
日本一のまぁとりあえず世界大会に出るには日本一になんないといけないので
日本一になるために
今　各お店とかでね
３月～４月くらいまで今予選が行われてて
で僕今回その大会に出たんですけども
一応、決勝まで行きました
一回戦、二回戦、準決、決勝ってあって
なんとか一、二、準決も勝って決勝まで行ったんですけど
決勝戦の結果、、、
勝ちましたーーーーーーー！！！！！ｗｗｗｗ
やったーーーーーーーー！！！！ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
アッハハwwwww
はい！というわけで
えーと店舗代表戦に今日実は行ってたんですよ
ごめんね！！
階段の動画の後編出す予定だったんですけどちょっとまさか
勝てると思ってなかったんで
このプレイマットももらえました！
これで僕はひとまず
まぁ日本代表のまず一歩を踏みだしたと言うわけで
ございます...！
そもそも店舗代表戦ってどんなのかというのをちょっと説明しますね
世界一を決める大会が今始まってて、
それのその予選が今色んな所で行われて
それに...出ました！
大会の流れ
はじめに、コナミカードゲームIDに登録！
出来た(^_-)-☆
でスッテプ１店舗代表決定戦が今行われています
第一期ですね
３月いっぱいまで第一期がやってて
まぁそれに僕実はですね..あのー...
土日出てたんですよ実は//
土曜日はまぁ惜しくも準決で負けてダメだったんですけども
今日ですよ！！
めっちゃ悔しくて！！ほんと正直、、
あのー、、
ずっと頑張って来たんすよ！
でその遊戯王楽しいなぁってこうもうちょっと楽しんでやってて
勝てたらいいなぁと思ってこう
勝つ楽しみを覚えだして結構一生懸命やってて
ほんとに寝る間も..惜しんで...朝まで友達と頑張ったときもあったり....
大会で一回戦で負けたこともあったり...
ここまで来るのにいろいろあった....！！！
それがようやくちょっとこう...開花したような...気がしました
まぁほんと出てる人たちはみんな世界一を目指してるわけですから中途半端な人がまぁ少ないわけで
バッッッチバチですからね！
たとえば皆さんの想像してる
俺のターン！！！！！
ドロー！！！！
召喚！！！！！
いけぇぇええ！！！！
みたいな感じじゃないですから
そうだねイメージ、、囲碁みたいな感じ！
将棋とか囲碁みたいな空気感
もう静かな場所でこう、、
結構怖いっすよ....
僕も最初怖かったんですけど
もう慣れると結構楽しいもんで
この静かな空間でいかにこう
相手の意表をついて何か出来るのかっていうのを考える、、感じです
公式大会というのはね
ごめんね話ずれたんですけど
でえーと店舗代表とりあえずお店の代表を決めていきます
で僕は今回、無事、お店の代表になることが出来ました！
俺の店といっても、、過言ではないなぁ...(ドヤ顔)
店長...ニヤッ
ごめんなさい
ブロック代表決定戦っていうのが５月から始まります
これで東海の代表とか、関東の代表九州の代表とかを決めていくわけでございます
ここが次のステップですね、、
まぁ５月からなんですけども
スッテプ３　日本代表決定戦　日本代表デュエリストを決定します
これが６月の下旬から７月に行われます
日本代表か、、、
まぁ僕でも店舗代表でも満足してるんですけど
まぁ行けるところまで行きたいです...
でステップ４　世界大会に出場！これで全世界からデュエリストが集まって世界一を決める大会でございます
遊戯王、、、すごいんだからな！！！？！
世界で大会とか、、イタリアとかで大会やってんだからね！？！？遊戯王
行きたいっ♪
はい、というわけであのほんとにね！！
すごい緊張した....！
ほんと手汗ヤバかったからね
プレイマットも頂いて！！
まぁ一安心したところでございます....
いや良かったほんとに良かった....！
なんかねーその
いつも一緒にやってる奴らで行ったんですけども
なんかみんなすごい喜んでくれてて
まぁ、、、楽しんでますよ！遊戯王は
僕はすごい楽しんで遊戯王やってるんですけども
まぁやっぱ出来れば勝ちたいなってのもあって、、
なんか遊びの中にもこう真面目に考えたシーンとかがあって
みんなで相談したりどうやったら勝てるのかってのを考えて
いつもやってくれてる奴らの支えがあって
あの....ほんといつも....朝遅くまで....一緒にやってくれてる仲間たちと....勝ち取った....
えー...価値ある優勝だと思っております
まぁカードゲームつったらただのカードゲームで遊びなんですけども！！
僕はすごい遊戯王に夢中になっててまぁ真剣に取り組めてるんで
何かに一生懸命になれるものを見つけられたのがすごい僕は嬉しいと思っております
いやほんともうねぇぇぇぇ。。。
ほんとに緊張したからね！！！？！
ちなみに自慢じゃないけど一回戦以外全部ストレート勝ちだ
店舗代表とかもう憧れでしたからね
心から良かったと思っております！！！
遊戯王最高！！！！！！！
と言いたいところなんですけども
まぁ今いろいろ言われておりますよね...遊戯王
知らない人がいたらごめんなさいなんですけども
４月からですね、遊戯王のルールがめちゃくちゃ、、変わって、、、しまいます、、、
今まで使えてたカードが一気に使えなくなるくらいすごいルール変更なんですけど
いろんな人いろんな文句言ってますけども
まぁ僕もね...こう...結構痛手を受けるデッキとかもあったんですけども
なんでもいいんすよ！！！
もう遊びでもいいし、趣味でもいいし、仕事でもいいし
何かに夢中になれるものがすごい欲しい！
そう思ってね、僕はYOUTUBEにも夢中になってるし
それにプラスして最近は遊戯王にも夢中になっております
なので多分ねルールがどう変わろうとも僕は遊戯王を楽しみたいと思ってるんで
４月からも遊戯王を楽しもうと思っております！！
まぁ遊戯王ルール変わってやめたい人はやめていいと思うし
やめない人はまぁ一緒に楽しもうって感じでございます
これはでも遊戯王を作ってる人たちが決めたことなんでもうそれに従うしかないんじゃないでしょうか
ぐちぐち言ってても仕方ないと僕は思います
というわけで！！！！
今後ははじめしゃちょー、遊戯王日本代表の権利を目標に頑張っていこうと思います
ひとまず最初のステップはクリアだ、、
無事！お店の中を全員ぶっ倒して俺が！NO１になったって話でした！！！
じゃあな！